so here's how Volkswagen got caught up  and arguably the largest Automotive  Scandal ever and stained a reputation  permanently Regulators were by no means  looking for an emission Scandal when  they started testing Volkswagen cars  they were actually just conducting a  boring old study that was trying to  identify the emissions differences  between European cars and American cars  and to accomplish this they hired five  scientists from West Virginia University  as scientists these five set out to  eliminated as many variables as possible  except for the ones that were being  studied one of the variables that they  eliminated was the emissions testing  system instead of using systems provided  by the manufacturer they use the  Japanese emission testing system for all  of the vehicles and this is when they  noticed something alarming Volkswagen  cars that weren't just emitting more  pollution than they claimed but they  were admitting so much that they were  breaking laws